my question is why can't a social
contract or a leading system replaced
religion as a moral framework and on
time I think it's because it's it's
because of the the gap between what we
articulate and what we don't know
something has to fill that gap like I
think the law could be could could
replace it if the law was total but it
isn't it's it's it's bounded and
incorrect and there's something it rests
it has to rest on something inside
that's like this mediator between what
we articulate and what we don't
understand it's something like custom
it's something like expectation it's
something like the intrinsic sense of
justice you know that the law itself is
aiming at and those aren't fully
articulated but without them there'd be
no grounding like without the body the
law would be a dictionary you know and
if you don't know what a word means
using the dictionary is helpful but not
that helpful because like unless you've
had the experience of anger the
dictionary can't tell you what anger
means it's just refers to other words
but the words themselves refer to
something else and the law refers to
something else and without that it has
to be in tune with that something else
and has to be in accordance with it and
so I I don't think we can ever delineate
the proper body of laws and that's also
why you like ideological utopians see
the unity illogical utopia is dispensed
with the transcendent they say this is
what we need to do it's like no you
don't know that's not good you have to
leave space for what you kind of know
and for what you don't know and I mean
you know in the story the Tower of Babel
human beings make this massive building
that's supposed to reach up to the
heavens so that it'll take the place of
God well that's that's the earliest
warning we have of the danger of making
things so big that you confuse them with
God and God gets irritated and comes
down and makes everybody speak different
languages and scatters them it's like
well that's what happens when you try to
make something a totality is that it
starts to fragment inside and and
disintegrates into katashi
and so it's it's almost as if we have to
maintain this articulated space inside
the dream inside the custom something
like that because otherwise it doesn't
work
and I think that's the same as having
respect for the fact that we have bodies
you know we're not just abstract
creatures that follow rules we're not
bad at all we only follow certain rules
we won't follow the other ones and our
societies will crumble and so and we
just don't know enough to articulate the
entire landscape of behavior with
articulated rules not at all we can't do
it it's beyond us